- All right, y'all,
let's close out this hour
with something fun and different.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat guitar music)
So you might not realize it,
but olive oil is just as
wide-ranging and layered as wine,
I didn't know that,
and there are just as
many varieties as well.
There's a new book coming out on June 14th
to help us non-professionals appreciate
what goes into a fine olive oil.
It's called "Extra-Virgin Olive Oil:
The Truth in Your Kitchen."
The author is a trained
professional olive oil taster,
one of three in the US
and one of 60 worldwide.
That's a small club, y'all.
No joke, he studied for
seven years to get certified,
and every year he has to go to Rome
to renew his credentials.
I mean, he has to go to
Rome? Cross to bear, I guess.
We have him on the line right
now, dialed in from Georgia,
where he watches on Fox 28 Savannah.
Let's say hi to David Neuman!
(audience cheering)
What's up, David?
So, how can I tell a fine
extra-virgin olive oil
from a knockoff?
- Well, extra-virgin olive oil, Kelly,
is the only food that by
law must be tasted by humans
to validate the claim on the label.
Most people don't know that.
We're gonna show you quickly today
how to smell and taste
olive oil as a consumer
to come up with your own evaluation
to make sure the bottle that
you have is extra-virgin.
- Okay, okay. What do I do?
- So we're gonna show you,
starting with an official blue glass.
- Okay. Oh, yeah, is there something-
- And in this glass...
We're going to put some of
the oil inside the glass.
Yours has been pre-poured.
Now, since you are a singer
and your vocal chords are
important to your life,
I'm gonna take one for the team
and taste the oil myself, okay?
- Oh, I'll taste it, watch me. Cheers!
- [David] Okay, cheers. Put
a little bit in your mouth.
- So, look for the bitterness and pungency
on your tongue in the back of your throat,
and then I'm gonna do a little slurping
that'll show you how we
accelerate the polyphenols,
which are the good, healthy
part of extra-virgin olive oil.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Oh, I'm not gonna do it
as a shot, but yeah, okay.
- Move it around your tongue.
It should be nice and green
and bitter on your tongue.
And as you swallow it,
you might feel little bee stings
in the back of your throat.
That's the good-
- Wait, what?
- [David] Healthy, fresh olive oil.
- Wait, what? I mean, I
don't want a bee sting!
- A little pepperiness in
the back of the throat.
- Oh, I get what you mean. Not like...
Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
I was a little afraid to do
that, but yeah. That's good!
- Extra-virgin olive oil has
been around for 4,000 years.
It's one of the oldest foods.
But there can be a lot of
mislabeling in the grocery store,
so you have to know what
extra-virgin olive oil is.
Fresh, real, extra-virgin olive oil
elevates everything in your kitchen,
and your friends and family
will be super impressed, Kelly.
- Oh, I love cooking with
it, so that's awesome.
Thank you so much, David.
I'm liking your post right
now, and this olive oil.
Remember, everybody, David's book
"Extra-Virgin Olive Oil:
The Truth in Your Kitchen"
is out June 14th.
Pick it up wherever you get your books.
But now...
Usually at this point
we'd give our guest $1,000
courtesy of Pilot Penmakers, of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
but today that check's going
to someone in the audience,
so if you wanna look under
your chair, someone has it.
(drum rolling)
Oh, I heard like, "Aw, it's not mine."
Oh, you found it!
(upbeat guitar music)
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh! That was so sad, because...
You can stand up!
That was so sad, because you heard...
You didn't even hear. You go, "Yeah."
You just heard a lot of like, "Aw."
- [Diana] I heard someone
else yell that was looking!
- [Kelly] What's your
name? Where are you from?
- Diana from Ontario.
- [Kelly] From Ontario? Oh, welcome!
- Thank you!
- Well, have fun with that $1,000.
Go shopping. Do something fun.
- Thank you so much!
- Or pay a bill, whatever
you wanna do with it.